Speaker 1: Today, we're going to be speaking
with Claudia Goldin, who's a professor of
economics at Harvard University and author
of the new book Career and Family, Women's
Sensually, Long Journey Toward Equity.
It's really great to have you on today.
I appreciate your time.
Speaker 5: I'm pleased to be here.
Speaker 1: So I think maybe to start our conversation,
it might be interesting as you catalog in
the book to talk about some of the catalysts
over the last 100 years that have led women
to enter the workforce in greater numbers
now than at any previous time.
Can you talk a little bit about kind of the
main highlights on these last hundred years?
Speaker 5: It's certainly so.
To begin with.
In fact, the most important change in the
labor force in almost every country in the
world has been the increase of women in the
workforce.
So, so this decision is sort of made by considering
what we call the opportunity cost of being
in the household.
So when paid work is more remunerative, it
it's worth more relative to home production.
You exit that household and you go to work,
you know, and this can come about because
real wages increase.
It can also come about because household production
is better alternatives.
All you have to think about is what it would
be like to bake bread yourself rather than
buying that.
Of course, lots of people bake bread and they
do a very good job.
But and it might also be furthered when social
norms and traditions change.
So you asked about the catalysts.
So technological change have lots of different
types, did it?
So the most important ones are the ones that
decreased the importance of what we call Brawne
work.
Now I'm really strong.
I'm strong into my husband and I know, but
there are a lot of men who is stronger than
I am, and it increased the value of brain
work.
That's really very important.
So and then there are the technologies that
made homes cleaner and their care less labor
intensive.
You know, we forget about the fact we take
for granted that we have clean water and sewage
removal.
We have flush toilets and central heating,
then household electricity.
And finally, there are those that enabled
women to control their fertility is really
very, very important.
And that led to an enormously large increase
in the age of first marriage and as late as
the 1970s, when the birth control pill finally
diffused among among young women.
So those are the main ones
Speaker 1: you have spoken about in the new
book.
You talk about the significantly increased
rate of women who get college degrees and
at a very top level, we know that at least
right now, this may change.
But at least right now, people with college
degrees have higher lifetime earnings.
Can you talk a little bit about the educational
component to this as well?
Speaker 5: Sure.
So I think that you're asking why it is that
women versus men get more degrees, so.
So the returns are extremely high on the margin.
All these, you know, the vast majority of
individuals who don't get a college degree
would do much better if they if they did.
That's not true for everyone, but it's true
on the margin.
But first, a few important facts that are
generally not known.
There have been more female college graduates
in the US than male college graduates since
around 1980.
So therefore, it didn't happen yesterday.
It didn't even happen ten years ago, began,
believe it or not, 40 years ago.
The second factor of importance is that one
high school graduation was a really important
milestone and when just 10 to 20 percent of
the nation's young people would cross that
threshold.
And I mean, like in the first quarter century
of the the first quarter of the 20th century,
women were the vast majority of high school
graduates.
That's an important fact.
And the third fact is that there are more
female than male college graduates and virtually
all the rich countries in the world and even
in the poorer countries, women are increasing
their numbers relative to men.
So we need to understand what's going on.
We have to take all of this into consideration.
So two facts or two notions.
The first is that work for men is still partially
brawn driven so guys can still do construction
work.
Go to any construction site.
How many women do you see?
Very, very few.
And so men, even without a college degree,
can still find work that we used to call good
work.
It's become less and less good, although the
demand for non-college graduates today is
very hard.
And the second point is that men are let's
call them males because most of them are very
young, don't get their act together until
later in life.
And this is reflected in just a host of risky
behaviors, from drugs to crime to those that
result in their own bodily harm.
And so those who study psychology and genetics
can point to some of the underlying reasons,
and it means that the boys don't write their
college essays on time and they don't apply
on time and they don't go when we.
Speaker 1: Talk about this issue with most
Americans who are sort of centered in the
political debates of our time.
A lot of the factors that you're talking about
to build up this foundation of our understanding
of the dynamics of the workforce often get
sort of tested by the final output, which
is what does pay look like and end questions
of pay disparity.
And for a very long time, this idea of the
77 cents on the dollar was being floated about
about eight years ago.
We did a kind of deeper dove into this and
and some of your research was actually part
of of what we used to figure out what are
maybe more accurate numbers.
And it seems that the 77 cent number is simply
not an accurate number from what I'm recalling
now from the research.
It seemed to be closer to 92 cents on the
dollar.
Some part of which might be due to discrimination.
Can you talk a little bit about that?
OK.
I know this is a huge can of worms.
I understand.
Speaker 5: As someone once said, a can of
worms larger than the universe, which is a
little scary.
So the first thing is that.
First of all, Tan, 77, is 82, I believe.
But it is an accurate number for something.
Everything's an accurate number.
If I told you the price of apples, you know,
in the corner store, that would be an accurate
number for the price of apples at the corner
store may not be the correct number for the
price of apples in San Diego or Omaha.
So that that's part of the issue.
So it is constructed by taking everyone in
the current population survey, taking their
weekly earnings for men and women, and using
only those who are full time year round.
So that that sort of standardizes and some
men are not entirely and then takes the median
for women and the median for men and divides.
That's a no.
It's an accurate number for what it's doing.
OK, here's the inaccuracies.
The inaccuracies are that for each woman,
the amount that she receives relative to men
changes over her lifetime.
We know that we know that for relatively young
men and women, their earnings are pretty similar.
You know, if I look at what happens to college
graduates who are law school graduates when
they first leave, their earnings are very
similar.
And then over time, they diverge and they
diverge a tremendous amount.
For those at the highest and the professionals,
so lawyers.
So to lawyers, my boss both go to a Park Avenue
law firm and then they marry.
They have kids and they realize it's unsustainable.
And so what happens is that it's often the
case that the woman will remain a lawyer but
move to a firm that smaller and less demanding,
less greedy.
The difference between their earnings that
ratio isn't 77, it's not 92.
It's often sixty four, you know, but we generally
don't observe in census data where we're since
we're narrowing this, we're looking at the
medians.
These are the very, very upper tail.
If we looked at the lower tail, then they're
going to be far more similar.
It's almost ironic have often been asked,
isn't the gender gap wider at the bottom?
I said, I'm going to be wider at the bottom.
We've got a we've got a bottom that's limited
by the minimum wage.
So it's not as if you have so much room at
the bottom, you have a tremendous amount of
room at the top.
And so that's that's the issue.
So it is a correct number, but it's not a
number that's going to tell us a lot about
what's happening to the individuals as they
go through their life cycle.
Speaker 1: That's very interesting.
So.
And with your study being in economics, you're
able to explore a number of different ways
of measuring this, depending on what is the
question that we are sort of trying to answer.
And then it seems that a second layer on top
of this would be if one wants to ask political
questions or societal questions about discrimination.
We need to be very careful about what are
the numbers that we're considering, it sounds
like.
Speaker 5: Absolutely.
I mean, it's my sense that there is no question
that there are disparities that we should
eliminate their sexual harassment.
There's disparities in terms of the ability
of individuals to go to a supervisor and ask
for a raise.
There is real discrimination, but it's my
sense and we have a lot of information that
shows this that even if we eradicated all
of that, and I hope we do eradicate all of
that, it's not going to close the gap because
much of the gap is due to this notion of greedy
work and the fact that in couples that are
different sex couples, they often abandon
gender equity.
As I just said with the couple who graduated
from law school and when they abandoned couple
equity, they throw gender equality under the
bus with it.
Speaker 1: When you are in the book, talk
about various anti-discrimination laws, training
for people in managerial and supervisory positions.
My understanding and my reading of it is you
do find that these initiatives are valuable,
but that they're not necessarily enough.
Is that fair?
Speaker 5: Yeah, I would say that there it's
not that they're not necessarily enough, they're
not really getting to the main problem.
Speaker 1: And when you if we really want
to fine tune or ascertain the problem, it
seems there's a number of components to some
degree.
I mean, you talked about the dynamic within
opposite sex couples and career choices that
exist there.
You talked about the difference between what
we might consider higher wage jobs rather
than than middle or lower wage jobs.
Can you talk to us about some of the other
specific points that should be looked at when
we are trying to identify exactly what the
problem to be addressed is?
Speaker 5: Certainly.
So the the problem in many ways is that work
a lot of work is very greedy.
And so when individuals couples are making
these choices, they can and they have care
responsibilities, they can both take the more
flexible job that allows them to respond to
emergencies that allows them a certain amount
of flexibility without penalty.
But if they do that and the world is very
greedy, there are leaving a lot of money on
the table.
It's really as simple as that.
Greedy jobs also impact those at the lower
end.
But that's a somewhat different story.
But it's it's the it's really the case that
for many couples, they're faced with a difficult
problem as to whose career is going to get
the upper hand, let's say.
But at the same time, there's no question
that both members of the couple lose out because
men lose out of the joys and and of of seeing
their family in the same amount of time that
women do and women lose out because their
careers are in many ways lowered and they're
lowered for their lifetimes.
Speaker 1: Last thing I want to ask about
programs like universal pre-K, publicly funded
child care, et cetera.
It might seem as though if these are funded
through taxes and they provide both parents
for lack of a better term with a more equalizing
opportunity to remain in the workforce in
a more engaged way, it would seem as though
programs like that might have an equalizing
force.
Is is that the case?
Speaker 5: Yeah.
So so let's think about it.
There are three types of solutions.
One is to lower the price of these flexible
jobs, make them more productive.
That that's the one that I that I spend a
lot of time on.
The second one is to lower the price of care
of children, not just children, but of the
elderly.
And that's another set of issues.
And the third type of solution is simply to
change gender norms because if in fact, when
given this choice there was random, then you
might throw a couple equity under the bus
that you wouldn't throw gender equality under
the bus with it.
OK, but let's talk about it's a somewhat separate
issue.
Talk about universal pre-K and public funded
child care.
That would certainly change the price of care.
It would drive it down relative to the amount
that you get from working.
By the way, it would also be the case that
if we changed tax policy, that would might
be a good thing to do too.
So if we didn't have joint returns, as is
the case in Britain and Sweden, then women
wouldn't in some sense be faced within the
family by the higher marginal tax rate.
So that would be a very good thing, too.
But the problem is that someone has to pay
for universal pre-k and childcare, and the
latter child care is extremely expensive and
anyone with children knows.
I mean, everyone complains.
It's very interesting that everyone with children
complains about the high cost of child care.
And at the same time, they complain that childcare
workers are paid too little.
That's right.
Speaker 1: Where do you think the costs come
from, right?
Speaker 5: It's it's it's it's a very, very
simple point.
If you have one child care worker for three
children, just do the math.
And it's very, very clear that if you're actually
if you're a child care worker is well-educated,
well, skilled and well-paid, it's going to
cost a tremendous amount.
So these are decisions for the parties.
Sweden decided that they didn't want to go
that route, not for infants, by the way.
For infants, they the one of the parents,
receives parental leave and is paid for that.
So as researchers, though, we can demonstrate
that pre-K increases the human capital of
the next generation verso pre-K.
You didn't say pre-K, you said universal,
and that's important.
By involving the entire community is actually
more effective than targeted pre-K.
So.
So that's sort of the answer.
Universal pre-K would be very, very nice.
I mean, let's face it, we have public education.
At what age should it begin?
You know, at some point in the 1920s 1930s,
it was decided that we should push it to five
years old or six years old and have this thing
called kindergarten.
At some point in the 20th century, we had
universal kindergarten.
So.
So there is no it's this is a matter of the
age of three year olds.
Four year olds can learn.
Right.
And so I think spoken as someone who has a
four year old.
Speaker 1: The new book is career and family
women's century long journey toward equity.
We've been speaking with the book's author,
Harvard University Economics Professor Claudia
Goldin.
I really appreciate your time and your insights
today.
Speaker 5: Well, thanks very much, David,
I've enjoyed it.